hello went to welcome to this video
playing poorly poorly benco or not ya
got the bank oh so poorly poorly yet he
forced probably the critical test even
though some people also go with g3 stuff
should 86 I'm currently studying with
this for a project that I'm then I'm
completing compiling a bank or gambit
repertoire to be released on a website
but i only have started very recently
and it's not some lines i have looked at
and should know reasonably well but some
line some i have not yet looked at and
this is something that I just started
with ok so yeah he really is often might
be five understandably we'll see
yes but it is somewhat slow right also I
mean night system
94-97 and it's probably not enough it's
probably not enough okay um 98 would
like to attack this though so probably
move the Queen take e four so that he
has to move the Queen now okay so 94
24-25 a beer luke a one mmm yeah this is
this is possible right I had something
very similar at the end it's at the same
position where at the end there was
Queen you 76 and I'm falling apart it
could be right I cannot really go back
anymore 27 hmm I think I've maybe I made
the same kind of mistake in earlier game
that's really that's possible the
problem is I cannot develop my night I
cannot develop my mind it's a big
problem he has to take a seven hour
absolutely somewhat this this this the
relatively best seems rupee one here or
you see it's not directly meeting me or
anything
okay so let's try rope you one
I would have had exactly the same stuff
it was very similar in nature but I only
recalled it after I was quick exit full
okay I mean it's not all that easy for
why to hand my hope if it takes these
six and i have this check but that
doesn't help me with my night so that
check it it's really not doing much okay
so this is not playing from made I think
he wants to go 94 okay but I can take be
five is that what's the problem here
Knight f6 or what to see I'm going to
see after
ah Pepsi three okay I'll take this check
okay i'm probably missing some tactical
idea here ships III or something what is
what is the threat here night h5 for
something or 98 97 it isn't what is the
thread
don't see it
my night is in the game check let's see
so if he comes back my takes eight stop
okay have to do him and I'm threatening
okay two things after Queen f7 can do
this and should i can play Jackie Bishop
give for this is good who care to Andrew
k 1 I don't see how he covers that yes
it should work so maybe here that's a
good defensive move check so this is
this is leading to me getting checkmated
so hi Marlee I do this here it's not not
not yet easy would like to cover that
but I don't don't see how him hmm and I
still kind of annoying here with the
with this but this stuff how to do it
this is made it is no no it's no maid
anymore this makes it a threat right
okay too it's a thread now
now this only queen of eight is just a
check man yeah threatening okay to
winning it's not too difference right
it's just one check check check
look at five and Bishop b3 made
checkmate yes 2500 06 whoa yeah that's
ex neither after that slump that I was
into getting back to above 2,500 okay
yeah I think it thanks to us some
openings also scoring fantastically well
I'm really scoring well with this bangle
gambit and the English an opening is the
total killer okay well not sure I mean
probably that was wrong I feel like I
had the same thing but the port oops i
had the same thing on the board before I
never forgot forgot it okay the computer
gives this as a playable line I kind of
thought about it but yeah who is
calculating that in a grid scammer this
is what the engine is giving check check
with the perpetual or repetition yeah
okay this is not working in check yeah I
think I had exactly the same thing and
I'm forgetting it it's a bishop's III
was good now it was strong yeah and this
is indeed winning light comes here yeah
I shouldn't do that a third time me two
times is already too much but yeah so
nitey suggest to a good friend and now
98 wins now as it was very lucky this
game 94 now wins
no 94 now is winning didn't see that
move I have to do something like that to
hang on and that is losing I cannot keep
keep this pawned if I somehow would keep
this pawn bishop Andrew can pawn could
be fortress ideas but nothing like that
it's a total loss Inez stumbled into
that after 97 i'm i'm basically winning
i think it's a total turnaround check
check yeah Bishop deform check check and
age five no I played this first okay but
it is winning at age five is a move and
then now are not make sure he made it
anymore check he has a draw here's a
draw yeah I'm such an idiot oh my god
Bishop Bishop e3 wasn't shining check
threatening Bishop g5 okay dokay okay he
has Queen hch 64 draw he has cruel a
chance oh my god that was lucky okay
thanks for watching